who goes first because I can tell I want
to talk about the first time I met you
in the circumstance and you can tell me
if you even remember because I remember
vividly do you really oh the very first
time we met oh yeah wow well because
it's the and I actually wrote about it
in my book what yeah it's in my book I
need to read Rob Lowe's book you do I
don't know I've done two and I'm not
well I've done two of them but I have
done two and I don't remember which one
it's in now I have to read them both
just to find out the my men see the way
I work oh my God see I'm like I just
want him to get two more um and I might
even get you one signed
um but okay so I am
probably 13 right I'm at Malibu Park
Junior High okay
and I want to be an actor right
um I'm fresh from Ohio I don't know
nothing about nothing
but I'm in all the school plays I'm in
I'm in every
everything talent show
and there is a pro for sure the most
talented girl in the school is was one
of my best friends
Holly Robinson right and Hollywood sing
Desperado
and Linda Ronstadt would come yeah and
sit in the front row and listen to Holly
saying Desperado
Holly's mother
and why Holly's mother isn't more
celebrated than she is is kind of I just
I just don't understand she's like the
zelig of of of of of modern Show
Business Robinson yeah and and she knows
everybody Dolores Robinson
I mean single African-American mom yep
raising two kids moved here from
Philadelphia if you're from Philly drove
her green Volvo station wagon across
country
with a dream yeah so and she is now I'm
so unsophisticated at this time that I
don't really understand that much about
Hollywood or what Dolores was or does
but she was a manager
and I was her only client at the time
was she she I would see around and she
stopped me in the hallway I can see it
like it was yesterday the upstairs
outdoor hallway
in the history building
and she said I want you to meet someone
because next week
he will be the most famous person in the
world
and it was you
the week before Roots came out wow
that's a good story and I remember
I just I mean I just remember and she
was right I mean think about think about
it I mean it's like
well that was the time the days when
that could happen yeah we're literally
overnight truly overnight obviously
worked you'd always had it no no nothing
Roots was my first professional audition
wait what yeah
yeah I was a sophomore at USC studying
theater with an intention to graduate
with a Bachelor of Fine Arts degree and
move to New York and hustle my way onto
the stage that was my intent and
intention
and I auditioned for roots in
um
early
76.
early 76.
and um that process went through the end
of of March
I did my first main stage role at USC I
played Ali Hakim in uh in Oklahoma
I played Will Parker
Parker how are you I'm fine how are you
doing I'm glad to meet you oh wow we
need to take this on the road didn't
they call him a pedal in The Peddler yes
that's the Ado and he called him the
peddling man she sure did Ado Annie yeah
it was Will Parker's girlfriend indeed
indeed she was Madeline Smith played uh
played Edo Annie in in the USC
production we went on to to play
opposite John Travolta in uh
in what was the cowboy movie he did
everything Urban Cowboy urban Urban
Cowboy Urban Cowboy ah I remember also
that that next week you I remember you
on the cover of Time Magazine right yeah
that was crazy what do you do where do
you go from the cover of Time magazine
in your very first audition
talk about being shot out of a cannon
and you know for the listeners who
weren't alive for roots and what it was
I mean it's it was such a I I can't
think of anything that was bigger I mean
honestly it was as big as Star Wars at
the time it was sure it it it had an
impact it made an impact my very first
day as a professional actor Cecily Tyson
played my mother
Maya Angelou played my grandmother well
I'm sorry who I'm sorry what Dr Maya and
whoa played my grandmother Neo boto in
in Roots and that very first day that's
that's those were my acting partners
what what
I know I look I'm I'm actually
speechless now I was what was he what
was what was that like was there any
poetry read please tell me is there a
LeVar Burton poem in the archives you
know what it was for me in those in
those early days it was it was being in
the makeup trailer in the morning with
with those women and and just being in
their presence was all I needed I didn't
have to eat or sleep I just needed to be
around them and just you know absorb
whatever I could and it was it was like
that for the entire seven weeks
um
Moses Gun G2 kombucha Liu all people
that I had admired you know growing up
and seen on television
um it was quite an extraordinary thing
and the weird thing is is that I don't
remember being particularly nervous
because I knew I'm I if I knew anything
at that point in my life I knew who
Kunta Kinte was
I knew it I knew who that character was
inside and out what do you think led to
that kind of awareness just my whole
life right I just knew how this young
man felt in any given situation
I just knew
I just I had that knowingness
isn't it it doesn't happen but it
doesn't happen all the time does it oh
God no right no and then when it does
I'm not sure what to attribute it to I
think there's a I I have I have felt a
sense of
um
I guess Destiny yeah in in my life I'm
I'm
sure you do too that that there are
things that that have transpired that I
could never have predicted and I am in
awe of and
and the only thing I can attribute it to
is that this was this was part of
somebody's plan right yeah and and and
it ain't it wasn't mine not at least on
not on a conscious level because if you
had given me you know pad and pen and
said so you know draw it up dream up
your career your career I I would not
have been this generous to myself yeah
same right oh
same and you know
my my first movie was The Outsiders and
that was a a big movie I thought all
movies were going to be like that
Francis Ford Coppola yeah I mean your
first director right come on man and you
don't come on I know I know you just
don't know and
it it's that's why I love meeting up
with
I mean someone like you I feel I don't
even know when the last time we
physically laid eyes on each other
decades yeah decades right at least a
couple gotta be right yeah sure and yet
you know what a history yeah
and as a sense of of kinship you know we
haven't seen each other in in eons but
you walked in the dorms like my God let
me hug this guy's face
[Laughter]